The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We do
have a little bit
of finishing to do because
we didn't quite finish
the dynamics of homogeneous
expansion last time.
So we'll begin by finishing that
after a brief review of where
we were last time.
And then we'll move on to
discuss non-euclidean spaces,
which I hope will be still
the bulk of today's lecture.
OK.
In that case, let's get going.
Again, as I said,
I want to begin
by just reviewing
some of the things we
talked about last time.
And you should consider
this a good opportunity
to ask questions if you discover
there are things that you're
not really sure you understood
as well as you'd like.
We were talking about the
evolution of a closed universe.
And to summarize that
calculation we first
re-shuffled the
first order Friedmann
equation, the equation for a
dot over a quantity squared,
by bringing all the d t's to
one side and all the d a's
on the other side after doing
a little bit of rescaling.
And we got this equation.
Which we then said
we can integrate.
And the integral from
time will go from time 0
to some arbitrary final time
that we called t tilde sub f,
where the "tilde" indicates
that we multiplied by c.
And the sub f means it's the
final time of our calculation.
And on the other side
we have to integrate
with corresponding
limits of integration.
Corresponding to t equals
0 is a equals zero.
So the lower limit
of integration is 0.
And the final limit
of integration
is just the value of a tilde
at the final time, whatever
that is.
Then we discovered
that we could actually
do the integral on the right
if we made a substitution.
And in the lecture last time
we did it in two stages.
But the combined
substitution is just
to replace a tilde
by cosine theta,
according to this formula, if
we combine the two substitutions
that we made last time.
And if we do that we could
integrate the right hand side.
And the integral
then gives us t tilde
f is equal to the
integral of that,
which is just this expression.
And the expression below that
is just the substitution itself.
How to relate a tilde to theta,
according to substitution
which gave us that formula.
So these two formulas
together allow
us to determine t tilde
sub f, and a tilde
sub f in terms of
theta and alpha.
And once we had that we
realized we no longer needed
to keep those sub f's
because that was really
just a way of keeping
track of our notation
during the calculation.
It holds for any theta sub f.
So it holds for any theta.
So then we just rewrote those
same formulas without the sub
f's.
And here we wrote it
removing the tildes,
replacing them by
their definitions.
And this was the final answer.
This describes the evolution
of a closed universe expressed
in this parametric form.
That is, we were not
able to explicitly write
a as a function of t, which
is what would have liked
to determine how the expansion
varied as a function of time.
But instead we introduced
the auxiliary variable theta,
often called the
development angle.
And in terms of theta we
can express both t and a,
and thereby indirectly have
an unambiguous relationship
between a and t.
Any questions about that?
OK.
Then we noticed that
those were, in fact,
the equations of a cycloid.
And I won't go through
the argument again,
but the key point is
that the evolution
of our closed universe scale
factor, as a function of time,
is described by
what would happen
if you had a disk rolling
on the horizontal axis
with a point marked on the
disk which was initially
straight down, and then as
the disk rolls that point
traces out a cycloid.
And that is exactly the
evolution of a closed universe.
It starts at size zero,
goes to a maximum size,
and then contracts again in
a completely symmetric way.
The contraction phase
is the mirror image
of the expansion phase.
And then we went on to calculate
the age of a closed universe.
And that was really more
of an exercise in algebra
than anything else.
The age is really given by
this formula to start with.
This expresses the age, t,
in terms of alpha and theta.
And the only problem with
that is that nobody really
knows what alpha and theta mean.
It's much more useful to have an
expression for the age in terms
of things that astronomers
directly measure.
And one needs two things
to replace alpha and theta.
And the kinds of things
astronomers directly measure
are things like the
Hubble parameter
and the mass density, where they
often express the mass density
in terms of omega where omega
is the mass density divided
by the critical density.
And that's what I chose
to do in the formulas
that we went on to derive.
So our goal is simply to
take that formula for t
and figure out how to express
the alpha and the theta that
appear in it so that we
can get an expression
in terms of h and omega.
And to do that, we'll
go one step at a time.
We started by just writing
down the Friedmann equation.
And the Friedmann
equation has an a in it.
And everything
else in it is rho,
which can be expressed in terms
of omega without any trouble,
and h itself.
So everything else in
it consists of variables
that we're accepting to be
part of our final answer.
So we could solve the Friedmann
equations for a or a tilde
and that will allow
us to eliminate
any a tilde's from
our expressions.
Next, alpha was
originally defined
in terms of this formula which
only involves rho and a tilde.
We now know what
to do with a tilde.
We could substitute
that formula.
And rho, we always
knew what to do with.
We could express that
in terms of omega.
So we can instantly
solve that equation
and get an equation for alpha
in terms of the quantities
that we want to appear
in our final answer.
And there's still one
more thing we need.
We need an expression for theta.
And theta we can get by
looking at the other of those
two parametric
equations, the one that's
not the "t equals" equation, but
rather the "a equals" equation.
And in this equation we know
everything except theta itself.
So we could substitute for a
over root k from up here- that.
And on the right
hand side we can
place alpha by that
expression and then the 1
minus cosine theta stays.
And now we could solve
this equation for theta.
I might just mention that,
in lecture last time I
actually mis-copied
this equation.
I forgot the factor of
omega in the numerator.
So if any of you
were taking notes
you can go back and
correct your notes.
But it's correct in
the printed notes.
And now it's
correct on a screen.
So this you could either
solve for cosine theta--
initially what I did was
to solve for cosine theta.
But then it turned
out to be more
useful to know
what sine theta is,
because sine theta appears
in that parametric expression
for the age.
So if you know cosine
theta you can, of course,
get sine theta because
sine theta is just
the square root of 1 minus
cosine squared theta.
And that's what we did.
And that's how we got
a square root here.
And since square roots
can have either sign,
there's a plus or
minus there which
depends on where you are in
the evolution of our universe.
The right hand side
here is always positive
because we define that
square root symbol
to mean the positive
square root,
where the plus or minus, in
the end, tells you the sine.
And sine theta itself--
we know what theta does.
It goes from 0 to 2 pi.
So sine theta
starts out positive
and after theta crosses
pi, sine theta is
negative for the second
half of the evolution.
Meaning, sine theta is negative
for the contracting phase
and positive for
the expanding phase.
We then put all that together
into the formula for CT,
which is alpha theta
minus sine theta.
The alpha becomes this factor.
And the theta minus sine
theta becomes the arc sine
of this expression, minus
or plus that expression,
where this is just sine
theta from that formula.
And it's minus sine theta, which
is why the plus minus becomes
minus or plus.
The signs get a little tricky,
but it's, in principle,
straightforward.
It all just follows
from this formula.
And if you know
the sine of theta
you have all your
problems solved.
So we put all that
together into a table.
This is just a copy
of the same formula
that we had on the
previous slide.
Theta is what appears in
this right hand column.
It's indicated as the sine
inverse of some expression.
It refers to that
expression-- an abbreviation.
So we know what theta does.
Theta just goes from 0
to 2 pi in quadrants.
At least, it pays to divide
it up into quadrants.
Sine theta is always
positive for the first half
and negative for
the second half.
And that means that we have the
plus sign, or the upper sign,
for the first half of
the motion and the minus
sign for the second
half of the motion.
Omega we could just
calculate in terms of theta.
No problem about filling
in the omega column.
And we know that we're
expanding for the first half
and contracting for
the second half,
so that really
completes the table.
And the important thing
when you're actually
using this formula is
to decide what theta is.
And once you have that,
the sine of that--
the inverse sine
of that-- well, no.
Excuse me.
Theta itself appears there,
and the sine of theta
appears there.
And theta itself you
have to figure out
which is the relevant
value in terms
of where you are
in the evolution.
The point is that sine
theta itself goes--
does not uniquely
determine what theta is.
OK.
That, I think,
completes our discussion
of the evolution of
closed universes.
I think it completes everything
that we did last time.
So are there any questions?
OK.
Good.
To finish our discussion
of the evolution
of matter-dominated
universes, we
go on to discuss open universes.
And open universes are
really the same algebra
as closed universes.
They just differ
by the sine of k.
Because one doesn't like to
deal with negative numbers,
I defined kappa to
be equal to minus k,
so that for our
open universes kappa
was positive while
k was negative.
Then I used a different
substitution for a tilde.
Instead of a tilde
being a divided
by the square root of
k, which in this case
would be the square root of a
negative number-- which, one
doesn't like to deal
with imaginary numbers
if one doesn't have any need to.
So instead, for
the open universe
I'm defining a tilde to
be a divided by the square
root of kappa, so that
a tilde is again real.
Then I'm going to skip
all the algebra here.
There's a little bit more of
it shown in the printed lecture
notes.
But there are no
new concepts here.
Everything is really
the same, conceptually,
as it was for the
closed universe.
One difference is
that this time,
instead of getting
trigonometric functions,
we find that we get
hypergeometric functions.
Hyper-- yeah.
Hyper trigonometric functions,
I think, is the right word.
That is, sinhs and coshs
instead of sines and cosines.
The formulas are very similar.
These are the formulas we get
for the open universe case,
compared to those formulas
for the closed universe case.
We get a change in
the order of-- instead
of theta minus sine theta, we
get sinh theta minus theta.
But that's what you
have to get if it's
going to turn out
to be positive.
Sine theta is always
less than theta.
So this is a positive quantity.
Sinh theta is always
greater than theta,
so this is a positive quantity.
And same for the second lines.
Cosh theta minus 1
is always positive,
and one minus cosine
theta is always positive.
So you really know which
order to write them in just
by knowing that you
want to write down
something that's positive.
So these formulas describe the
evolution of the open universe
exactly the same way as those
formulas describe the evolution
of a closed,
matter-dominated universe.
So any questions?
OK.
Next step, just repeating what
we did for the closed universe,
we can derive a formula for
the age of an open universe.
And again, it's
really just a matter
of substituting into
the formula we already
have to be able to re-express it
in terms of useful quantities.
Which, again, I choose to
be the Hubble expansion
rate and omega.
And here I've put together all
three formulas for the age.
The flat universe,
the first one we
did, where t is just h
inverse if we bring it
to the other side, times 2/3.
And the open universe on the
top, and the closed universe
on the bottom.
Now one of the, perhaps
surprising, things
that one finds here is that
all three of these expressions
look fairly different
from each other.
And you might think
that that would
give some kind of a jagged,
discontinuous curve.
But you can go ahead and
plot it, which I did.
And there's the plot.
It's one nice, smooth curve.
And we won't go into this
in detail, but many of you
have had courses in complex
functions, functions
of a complex variable.
If you know about functions
of a complex variable
you can tell that these are,
in fact, all the same function.
That is, if omega is,
say, bigger than 1,
this formula can be
evaluated straightforwardly.
It involves only things
like square roots
of positive numbers.
But you could also try
evaluating this formula
for omega bigger than 1.
And then you have square roots
of negative numbers appearing.
But square roots
of negative numbers
are OK if you know
about complex numbers.
They're just purely imaginary.
And then you get trigonometric
functions, and even
inverse trigonometric functions,
or inverse hyperbolic trig
functions of
imaginary arguments.
But all those are well-defined.
And if you work through
what the definitions are,
the top line really is
identical to the bottom line.
Those really are
the same function.
And that's why one expects
that, when you plot them
they will join together
smoothly, as they clearly do.
The point in the middle
here is the first age
that we derived for
the flat universe
where omega is equal to 1
and h t is just equal to 2/3.
That is, t is equal
to 2/3 h inverse
for a flat universe,
which is the middle dot.
And the closed universes
are on the right
and open universes
are on the left.
OK.
Any questions about
these age calculations?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I noticed that,
for the open solution,
there's a case where you
get some imaginary numbers?
PROFESSOR: If you
use these formulas
you don't get any
imaginary numbers.
But if you tried to use,
say, the bottom formula
for a value of
omega less than 1 it
would give you
imaginary numbers.
And it would, in
fact, if you trace
through what those
imaginary numbers do,
it would give you the
formula on the top.
So it's all consistent.
It's most straightforward
to use the formula
on the top for omega less
than 1 and the formula
on the bottom for
omega greater than 1.
And then one never
confronts imaginary numbers.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
OK.
Where are we going next?
Finally, just actually
one last graph
on the evolution of
matter-dominated universes,
which is the final
form of a of t
for a matter-dominated universe.
If you re-scale things
by dividing a over root
k by alpha, and c t over
alpha-- if you look back
at our equations--
let me go back
to where the equations were.
We're really just
graphing these equations.
If I divide this
equation by alpha,
I just get a pure
function of theta
with dimensionless variables.
And similarly here, if I
divide a over root k by alpha
I just get 1 minus cosine
theta, which is a pure number.
So that's what
I've chosen to do.
And the dimensionality works the
same for the open case as well.
So it allows you to
draw a plot which
is just independent
of parameters.
All the parameters are
absorbed into the way
the axes are defined,
which are both
defined as
dimensionless numbers.
And in that case
the closed universe
survives for a duration of 2 pi.
The axis here, at least, has
the same duration as theta.
It's not actually theta, because
t is not linear in theta.
But this point
does change by 2 pi
as theta goes from 0 to 2 pi.
And one can see here, the
three possible curves.
A closed universe which
starts and then falls back,
a flat universe which
goes off to the right
and has actually a constant
slope as you go out here,
and an open universe which
behaves slightly differently.
Actually, I think
I was wrong when
I said the flat universe
has a constant slope.
But the open and the flat case
are similar to each other.
They both go off to infinity,
but in different ways.
And all three of them merge
as you go backwards in time.
That's not something that
might have been obvious
before we wrote
down the equations.
But in very early
times all universes
look like they're
flat universes,
if you go to early enough times.
And that actually is
an important point
which we'll talk
about later in terms
of what's called the flatness
problem of cosmology.
That basically is the
consequences of that fact.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why
didn't you just say
all of them looks like
open universes [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: I mean, what's
special about flat universes?
PROFESSOR: Well,
actually, there is
something special about flat.
Which is that, if we plotted
omega as the function of time
all of them approach omega
equals 1 as time goes to 0.
So there is a very
definite meaning
of saying that they're
all approaching flat,
rather than they're all
approaching open or closed.
Good question, though.
Because from this
graph you really
can't tell anything
special about the flat.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So does this mean
that the open and flat solutions
will extend indefinitely?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The open and flat solutions
extend indefinitely in time.
That's right, they do.
And one can see that from
the formulas or the graph.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So for plotting
omega as a function of time,
I'm a little bit
confused as to how
it changes as-- for example,
an open universe expands,
or a closed universe--
because it seemed
like, from our calculations,
that when the universe was
expanding, omega was increasing?
Is that-- at least
for a closed universe?
PROFESSOR: That is
true for a closed
universe during the
expanding phase.
For a closed universe
during the expanding phase,
omega does increase.
It starts out as 1
and then it rises
to infinity when the universe
reaches its maximum size
and is about to turn
around and go back.
Because it doesn't mean
the mass density increases.
That's maybe what's
confusing you.
The actual mass density always
decreases as it expands,
but the critical density
decreases even faster.
So the ratio, omega, actually
rises for a closed universe
as it expands.
For an open universe
it's the reverse.
omega starts
out being 1 at
early times, as it
does for any
matter-dominated universe.
And as the universe
expands, omega
gets smaller and smaller
for an open universe.
And it follows-- I don't
have them on slides here,
but we do have in
the notes formulas
that we derived, that we did
on the blackboard, that give us
omega as a function of theta.
And those formulas, you
can just look at them
and see how omega behaves
as the universe evolves.
Because as the universe
evolves, theta just increases.
And those formulas
do trivially show
what I said about
how omega evolves.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why a over alpha root
k, but for a flat universe k
is 0?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I didn't really say that,
but for the flat universe
there's an arbitrary
normalization
that one chooses in
drawing this graph.
And it was really an
arbitrary choice for me
to draw the flat case
to join on smoothly
with the open and closed cases.
I could have put any constant
in front of t to the 2/3.
And you're right, then
they would not necessarily
mesh unless I chose that
constant in the right way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Based on that, is
there a particular reason
you decided to chose [INAUDIBLE]
a flat universe looks
like this?
Is there a particular
thing you're
trying to show in
choosing [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is, is
there a particular reason
why I chose the
normalization that I chose?
If I did not choose
it, it would only
differ by an overall factor.
So it would still
look-- the flat line
by itself would look
indistinguishable, really.
It would just be
higher or lower.
So the only question is how
it meshes with the others.
And since the flat
case really is
the borderline between
the other two cases,
and since this constant
that appears in front of t
to the 2/3 has no
physical meaning whatever,
it seems the
sensible thing to do
is to plot it so that
it looks like the limit
of an open or closed universe.
Because physically it is the
same as the limit of an open
or a closed universe
coming from either side.
Any other questions?
Those are good questions.
OK.
In that case, we are
finished with the evolution
of matter-dominated
universes, and ready to start
talking about
non-euclidean spaces.
So what we'll be doing next
is kind of a mini introduction
to general relativity, which
how non-euclidean spaces
enter physics.
Now, needless to say,
general relativity
is an entire course
separate from this course.
And of course that even
has more prerequisites
that this course
has, so we're not
going to duplicate
what would be taught
in the general relativity class.
But it turns out
that the discussion
of general relativity does,
in fact, divide pretty
cleanly into two major issues.
And we will be dealing with
one of those issues but not
the other.
In particular, what we
will be doing in this class
is learning how the formulas
of general relativity
is used to describe
curved spaces.
And we will learn how particles
move in curved spaces.
So we'll be able to
analyze trajectories
in any curbed space
if somebody tells you
what the curved space
itself looks like.
What we will not be
doing is we won't even
attempt to describe how general
relativity predicts that matter
should cause space to curve.
That would be left
entirely for the GR course
that you may or may not take.
But it will not
be discussed here.
There's only one
point where we will
need a result of that sort.
We'll want to know how the
matter in our Friedman Roberson
Walker universe
affects the curvature.
And there I would just
give you the result.
I'll try to make
it sound plausible.
But I won't make
any pretense being
able to drive that result.
That is, we will not be able
to drive how much space curves
as a consequence of the
matter that's in it.
But we will write
down the answer
so you at least know
what the answer is
for a homogeneous
isotropic universe.
So here's a picturesque
slide about curve space.
Four years ago, I
think it was, a postdoc
here named Mustafa Amin
gave this lecture for me
because I was out of town.
And he had much more colorful
transparencies than I ever do.
So I'll be using some of
his transparencies here.
And this is one of
his opening slides.
So this is what we want to
talk about-- curved space
as illustrated in
that nifty picture.
So I want to begin with a kind
of an historical introduction.
To be honest, I'm pretty
much following the logic
of the first chapter of Steve
Weinberg's General Relativity
book.
Non-Euclidean geometry
of course starts
by thinking about
Euclidean geometry and then
how one might be
move away from it.
And historically, there's
kind of a clear cut
path, which was followed.
Euclid based his geometry, as
described in Euclid's elements,
in terms of five postulates.
The first of which is that
a straight line segment
can be drawn joining
any two points.
Sounds clear enough.
Second, any straight
line segment
can be extended indefinitely
in a straight line.
Also sounds obvious, which is
what Euclid was banking on.
Third, given a
straight line segment,
a circle can be drawn having
the segment as a radius and one
endpoint as the center.
That also-- you can imagine
yourself doing that--
seems straightforward enough.
But then we come to
the fifth postulate,
which still sounds
pretty obvious.
But it's certainly much more
complicated than the others.
The fifth postulate says that
if a straight line falling
on two straight lines makes the
interior angle on the same side
are less than two right angles,
the two straight lines--
if produced
indefinitely-- meet on
that-- I think
this is mis-typed.
Mustafa typed it.
I guess he's typed
this one, too.
This one shows the picture.
Yeah, this should be
on that side in which
the angles are less
than two right angles.
So let me just explain it,
independent of the text.
The question is,
what happens if you
have one line-- the line that's
shown more or less vertical
here-- and two lines
that cross it such
that the interior angles--
here shown as a and b--
are on one side less than pi.
Less than two right angles is
the way you could describe it.
Then, as you can see
from the picture,
these lines will
meet on this side
and will not meet on that side.
And that's what
the postulate says
that under those circumstances
where two lines cross a given
line such that the
sum of the two angles
adds up to less
than pi on one side
that the lines will
be on that side
and will not be
on the other side.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What
was his motivation
for making this the
fifth postulate?
It seems kind of arbitrary.
PROFESSOR: OK, the question is
what was Euclid's motivation
for making this the
fifth postulate?
Well, I have to admit I
haven't had many conversations
with Euclid so I'm
not sure I know
the answer to that question.
But it was what was needed to
basically complete geometry
as we know it.
So much of what you've
learned in geometry
would not be there if there
was not something equivalent
to this postulate.
But actually what I'm going
to be talking about next
is there has been
discovered there
are a number of substitutes
for this fifth postulate.
Mathematicians studied
for a long time
whether or not this
postulate could
be derived from the others
since it seems so much more
complicated than the others.
And there was a strong
desire during thousands
of years really-- at
least over 1,000 years--
among mathematicians to try
to prove the fifth postulate
from the first four postulates.
And nobody ever
succeeded in doing that.
And we now are pretty clear that
it's not possible to do that.
That the postulate
is independent
of the other postulates.
It was discovered along
the way that there
are a number of equivalent
statements to fifth postulate.
And you could equally well have
chosen any one of these four
statements that are
illustrated in these pictures.
And I'll give you
words one by one
for what these alternative
versions of the fifth postulate
would be.
A, up here, illustrated there,
says that if a straight line
intersects one of two parallels,
meaning two parallel lines--
so this is the one
line intersecting
two parallel lines.
If it intersects one of them
as the heavy part of the line
shows, then the theorem says
that if you continue that line
it will always
intersect the other.
And certainly obvious from
the picture, that's the way
it works.
But that's equivalent
to the fifth postulate
and not provable from the
other four postulates.
A second statement--
b is the one
that's illustrated there--
is the one that I remember
learning when I was in
high school, I think,
which says that if you have one
line and another line parallel
to it-- or rather, I'm sorry
another point off the line
that there's one and only
one line through that point
parallel to the original line.
So that is yet another statement
of this famous fifth postulate.
Number c is less obvious.
But it turns out
that once you go away
from Euclidean geometry,
your space always
has a built in scale.
So things are not scalable.
One example I might mention at
this point of occurred space
is, say, the
surface of a sphere.
And the service of a
sphere has some fixed size.
So if you have a
figure of one size,
and you wanted, on the
surface of this sphere,
to make a figure 5 times bigger,
it might not fit on the sphere
anymore.
So you can't always
make a figure bigger
on the surface of the sphere.
In fact, you could
never make a figure
bigger without
bending in some way
on the surface of the sphere.
So that gives rise to
this third statement
of the fifth postulate, which
is that, given any figure,
there exists a figure
similar to it of any size.
And by similar it means
that for polygons they're
similar if the corresponding
angles are equal to each other
as they're supposed to
be on those two images.
And the corresponding sides
are proportional to each other.
So a similar figure
is just a blow up--
a rescaling-- of
the original figure.
And you can only do it if
the fifth postulate holds.
You can do it on a flat space
but not on a curved space.
And I think that is a
less obvious version
of the fifth postulate.
And finally, the
fifth postulate is
linked to the
behavior of triangles.
We all learned in
Euclidean geometry
that the sum of the three angles
of a triangle is 180 degrees.
That is a crucial theorem
of Euclidean geometry that
depends directly on the fifth
postulate and is, in fact,
equivalent to the
fifth postulate.
So you could assume it and
forget the fifth postulate
and still prove everything.
So the fact that--
actually, I'm sorry.
It is equivalent to
the fifth postulate.
But you don't need
to assume that it's
true for every triangle to
prove the fifth postulate.
It turns out that sufficient
and mathematicians always
look for the minimum
axiom to be able to prove
what they want to prove.
The minimum version of
the axiom for triangles
is to simply assume that
there's just one triangle who's
angles add up 180 degrees.
And if there exist just one
triangle whose angles add up
to 180 degrees, then
the fifth postulate
has to hold-- turns out--
which is not so obvious, again.
So these are all
different, equivalent ways
of staying in the
fifth postulate.
But it's pretty clear
now that it's not
possible to prove the fifth
postulate from the first four.
Any questions about that?
OK, so a little
bit of history now.
The first person, apparently,
to seriously explore
the possibility that the
fifth postulate might be wrong
was a Jesuit priest named
Giovanni Geralamo Saccheri.
I'm sure other
people can pronounce
it much better than I can.
And in 1733, which is
the same year he died,
he published a study of
what geometry would be like
if the fifth postulate
did not hold.
And he titled it- this
is a lot title, which
I don't know how to
pronounce really,
but in English it's
apparently translated
as Euclid Freed of Every Flaw,
treating the fifth postulate
as kind of a flaw in Euclid's
axiomization of geometry.
Saccheri was, in fact, convinced
that the fifth postulate
was true.
He didn't really want to
consider the possibility
that it was false.
But he was nonetheless
exploring the possibility
that it was false
because he understood
the concept of a proof
by contradiction.
He was looking for
a contradiction
to be able to prove that
mathematics would not
be consistent if you assume
the fifth postulate was false.
And therefore, the
fifth postulate
would be proven to be true.
So he was exploring
what would happen
if the fifth
postulate was false,
looking all the time to
find some inconsistency,
and was not able to find any.
So he considered all
of this a failure.
But he published it anyway.
And that's the
publication front page.
The next person to enter
the stage-- or actually
three people
together, but I only
have a nice
transparency on Gauss.
Gauss, Bolyai, and
Lobachevsky went on
to seriously explore the
possibility of geometry
without the fifth
postulate, actually assuming
that the fifth
postulate is false,
developing what we call GBL,
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry.
Gauss was a German
mathematician.
These were the years he lived.
He, in fact, was born the
son of a poor, working class
parents, which I found
a little surprising.
We kind of think of scholars
in those early years
as being gentleman who
were part of the nobility.
But Gauss was not
but, nonetheless,
went on to be one of the
most important mathematicians
of his age.
One of the other things
that surprised me
and to be honest I just learned
all this from Wikipedia.
I'm no real expert
on the history.
But they gave a list
of Gauss' students.
And they included that Richard
Dedekind, Bernhard Riemann,
Peter Gustav Lejeune Dirichlet,
which is the name I remember,
Kirchhoff, and Mobius.
So quite a list of
famous mathematicians.
So I have to admit, when
I read that, I was just
about to send off an email
to all of my former students
saying, look, what's
happening here?
You're not competing
at all. [LAUGHING]
But I decided not to do that.
It would be impolite.
And who knows?
Maybe 100 years
from now my students
will be as famous as these guys.
You never know.
We can plan, I hope.
OK, so the other guys involved
in this and they were all
working independently were
Bolyai who was, I think,
a Prussian military man,
actually, and Lobachevsky
who was also a professional
mathematician working
in the university.
The three of them independently
developed a geometry
in which the fifth postulate
was assumed to be false.
There are two ways
it could be false.
In version with the triangles,
for example, a triangle
could have more than or
less than 180 degrees.
Since there were assuming that
the fifth postulate was false,
it meant they had to be assuming
that every version that we just
talked about of
the fifth postulate
is false because they are
all equivalent to each other
and these people realize that.
So in particular in the
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry, there are
infinitely many lines parallel
to a given line.
And no figures of
different size are similar.
And the sum of the
angles of a triangle
are always less than
180 degrees or pi,
depending on whether you're
a radian person or a degree
person.
Now I should mention here
that the surface of the sphere
is, in fact, a
perfectly good example
of the non-Euclidean geometry.
But for some reason it
was not taken seriously
by mathematicians until
long after these guys
were doing their work.
And part of the reason, I guess,
is that the surfaces three
evaluates not just
one of Euclid's axioms
but two if we go back
to Euclid's axioms.
The second of Euclid's axioms
said that any straight line
segment can be
extended indefinitely
in a straight line.
And the surface of the
sphere and the analog
of the straight line
is a great circle.
And if you extend
the great circle,
it comes back on itself.
So the surface of the sphere
violates the fifth postulate.
But it also violates
the second postulate.
But still perfectly
consistent geometry,
and it is a
non-Euclidean geometry.
And on the surface
of this sphere,
these statements
all kind of reverse.
Instead of having infinitely
many lines parallel to a given
line, you have no lines that
are parallel to a given line.
Remember, lines are great
circles and lines are parallel
if they never meet.
But any two great circles meet.
So there are no lines
parallel to a given line
in the geometry of the
surface of the sphere.
It's, again, true that no
figures of different size
are similar.
That has to be true
for any any geometry
where the fifth
postulate was false.
The last one,
again, has a choice.
And it's the opposite
choice for a sphere
as for the
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry.
In the Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
Bolyai- geometry,
the sum of the angles is
always less than 180 degrees.
If you picture a
triangle and a sphere,
you can imagine that the
edges look like they bulge.
And the sum of the
angles on the surface
of the sphere of a
triangle are always
greater than 180 degrees.
The easiest way to
convince yourself
that that's true in at
least one important case
is to imagine a triangle.
Here's a sphere.
Everybody see the sphere?
There's the North Pole.
There's an equator.
Imagine a triangle
where one vertex
is at the North Pole and the
liver disease or on the equator
and the triangle
looks like this.
And these are both 90
degree angles down here.
So you already have 180 degrees.
And any angle you
have on top just
adds to the 180
degrees putting you
above the Euclidean
value of 180 degrees.
So for a sphere it's
always the opposite
of this greater
than 180 degrees.
OK, continuing with Gauss,
Bolyai and Lobachevsky,
their work was based on
exploring the axioms of Euclid,
assuming the reverse
of the fifth postulate
in any one of its forms.
And they proved
theorems and wrote,
sort of, their own versions
of Euclid's elements.
But that still left
open the question
whether or not all of this
was really consistent.
That is, from the
thinking of Saccheri
that we already talked about,
there's always the chance
that you might find the
contradiction even if you
haven't found a
contradiction yet.
And Gauss, Bolyai
and Lobachevsky
didn't really have any
way of answering that.
They didn't really
have any way of knowing
whether if they
continued further
they might find
some contradiction.
So what they did certainly
extracted the properties
of this non-Euclidean geometry.
But it did not really prove
that the non-Euclidean geometry
was consistent.
That happened slightly
later in an argument
by Felix Klein, who was the
same Klein as the Klein bottle,
by the way.
And that was his
famous paper on this
was published in 1870 somewhat
later than the early work
that we're talking about.
And what he did is he gave an
actual construction of the GBL
geometry.
And by construction
I mean in terms
of coordinates using coordinate
geometry ideas, which
were originally
developed by Descartes.
That's why we call them
Cartesian coordinate systems.
So what he gave as a description
of the Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry was a space
that consisted of a disk
with coordinates x and y just
as Descartes would have done.
He restricts himself to
the inside of the disk.
So he restricts
himself to x squared
plus y squared less than 1.
And what he gave was a
function of two points
in this disk where the
function represents
the distance between
those two points.
He decided that
distances don't have
to be Euclidean
distances if we're
trying to explore
non-Euclidean geometry.
So he invented his
own distance function.
And it's pretty
complicated looking.
The function he came up with was
that the cosh of the distance
between points 1 and 2 divided
by sum number a-- and a
could be any number-- is
equal to 1 minus x1 times x2--
these are the two
x-coordinates for points 1
and 2-- minus y1 y2 over
the square root of 1 minus
x1 squared minus y1 squared.
Sorry, it's the product of two
square roots in the denominator
here.
And the second square
root is the same thing
for the two coordinates 1 minus
x2 squared minus y2 squared.
So this formula is certainly
not obvious to anybody.
But Klein figured out
that this actually
does-- the geometry
described by these formulas--
reproduce completely
the postulates
of the Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry,
including the failure of
Euclid's fifth postulate.
And since this boils
down to just algebra,
if algebra is
consistent, it proves
that the
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry is consistent.
Now, as I understand it, nobody
can prove that any of this
actually is consistent.
People prove
relative consistency.
So in the assumption that
algebra is consistent,
theorems about the real
numbers are consistent.
Felix Klein was
able to prove that
the Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry is consistent.
And this was really
the beginning
of coordinate geometry.
I'm sure all of you
are rather familiar
with coordinate geometry.
It's a standard topic
now in math courses
and even in high school.
And this is really
where it began.
Euclid had no idea
that it was any value
in trying to represent geometric
quantities as equations.
Euclid did everything
in terms of theorems.
But this opened up
a whole new door
for how to discuss geometry.
So the geometry is a slide that
just shows the same formula.
And I guess this is supposed
to be an image of the disk.
One thing I should
point out, which
I forgot to point out, which is
that although this disk looks
finite, it really is an infinite
space that's being described.
And one can see that
by looking carefully
at the distance functions.
As either one of
these two points--
point 1 or point 2--
approaches the boundary
x square plus y square
equals 1, this square
root denominator blows up.
So the distance between a
point and another point that's
approaching the boundary
goes to infinity
as that point
approaches the boundary.
So boundary's actually
infinitely far away
even though in
coordinates they are still
x squared plus y
squared equals 1.
So this introduces
another important concept,
which we'll be using in
general relativity, which
is the coordinates don't
represent distances.
Distances could
be very different
from the way the
coordinates look.
So that boundary,
even though it looks
like it's right there
on the blackboard,
is actually very far away
from the other points.
OK, so after Klein,
the important new idea
that Klein introduced
was, first of all,
the explicit construction
but also the general idea
that you can describe geometry
not by giving postulates
but instead by actually
doing a construction where
you've given names to the
points in terms of coordinates
and you describe what
happens geometrically
in terms of some distance
function which describes
the distance between
two arbitrary points.
And Gauss went on to make
two other very important
observations about
geometry, which
has become essential to
our current understanding
of non-Euclidean geometry.
So let me mention two other
ideas that Gauss introduced.
The first one was
the distinction
between what he called
inner and outer properties
of a curved surface.
His curved spaces were
all two dimensional,
so they were surfaces.
So this is most easily
described for say
a surface of a sphere
where we can all
visualize what
we're talking about.
The surface of a sphere we
visualize in three Euclidean
dimensions and we
think of its properties
as being determined by that
three dimensional space.
And the geometry of that
And of course the
three dimensional space
is Euclidean that we're
embedding our sphere into.
But the non-Euclidean
aspects are all
seen in the geometry of the
two dimensional surface.
Figures drawn on the surface
as if the rest of the three
dimensional space did not exist.
And that is this key idea of
inner versus outer properties.
The outer properties
of the sphere
are properties that relate
to the three dimensional
space in which the
sphere is embedded.
But what Gauss realized
is that there's
a perfectly well defined
mathematics contained entirely
in the two dimensional space
of the surface of the sphere.
You could discuss it
without making any reference
to the three dimensional space
around it if you wanted to,
it's just a little
more complicated to be
able to do that.
But we will in fact be doing
it explicitly very shortly.
And all it amounts to
from our point of view
is assigning coordinates to
the points on the surface
of the sphere and the distance
function for those coordinates.
And then one has
a full description
of this two dimensional
space consisting
of the surface of the sphere
which no longer needs make
any reference to
the third dimension
that you imagined the
sphere embedded in.
So the study of the properties
of that two dimensional space
is the study of the inner
properties of the space.
And if you care about
how it's embedded,
that's called the
outer properties.
And Gauss made it clear in
the way he described things
that from his point of view, the
real thing that mathematicians
should be doing is studying
the inner properties.
The outer properties are
not that interesting.
So that's one key idea
that Gauss introduced.
And the second is the idea
of what we now call a metric.
And there are really
two pieces to this.
The first of which
is that instead
of giving macroscopic distances,
which is what Klein did,
he told you how to write down
a formula for the distance
between any two
points, Gauss realized
that things could
become more interesting
if instead of trying to
immediately write down
a function for the distance
between two arbitrary points,
you can find your attention
to very nearby points.
And consider the
distance between two
far away points
as just the length
of a line that joins them
where every little segment
in the line is a short distance
which is governed by the rules
that you've made up
for short distances.
So if you understand
short distances,
long distances are
obtained just by adding.
That's the basic idea.
So only short
distances are needed.
And then there's
another important idea
which is that the short
distances themselves
for an interesting
class of spaces
should not be some arbitrary
function of the coordinates
of the two points but should in
fact be a quadratic function.
And in two dimensions,
a quadratic function
mean something like
this, where gxx is just
any function of x and y, x
and y are the two coordinates
of the space.
gxy is also just any
function of x and u.
gyy is any function and gxx
multiplies the x squared,
xy multiplies the x times dy and
g sub yy multiplies dy squared.
And there's no terms portion
for dx by itself or dy by itself
or dz by itself.
And there's no
terms proportional
to the cubes of those
quantities, it's all quadratic.
That's the assumption.
Now what underlies
that assumption is not
that all spaces have
to have this property.
This does narrow one down to
a particular class of spaces.
But one way of
characterizing that class
is that what Gauss understood
is that that class, the class
of spaces described
by a metric like this,
are precisely the class of
spaces which are locally
Euclidean, meaning that even
though the surface is curved,
any tiny little patch of it
looks flat and can be covered
by Euclidean coordinates,
redefining coordinates
in that one little patch only
where the metric in the one
little patch would just be
the Euclidean metric given
by the Pythagorean theorem
of Euclidean geometry,
dx prime squared
plus dy squared,
which would be the distance
function for a flat space
and ordinary
Cartesian coordinates.
And it turns out
that saying that this
is true in every
microscopic region
is equivalent to saying that
the metric over the entire space
can be written as
a quadratic form,
meaning one that looks
exactly like that.
And spaces that
have this property
are now usually called
Riemannian spaces,
even though it was Gauss
who first identified them.
And all the spaces that
we deal with in physics,
in particular the spaces we
deal with general relativity,
will be Riemannian spaces.
Or sometimes they're called
pseudo Riemannian spaces
because time is treated a little
bit differently in physics.
And the word
"Riemannian" was really
built on spatial geometry.
But the word
"pseudo" only changes
the fact that this becomes the
Lorenz metric, if you know what
that means, instead of
the Euclidean metric.
But the same idea
holds, which is
that the spaces that
we're interested in
are spaces which locally
look exactly like flat space.
And that implies that globally,
you can always write down
a metric function which is
quadratic, as Gauss said
So the metric should be
a quadratic function that
specifies the distance only
between infinitesimally
separated points, not
finitely separated points
and should have the
form of ds squared
is equal to some
function of x and y times
dx squared plus a different
function of x and y times dx
times dy plus a different
function of x and y times dy
squared.
So I'm just writing the same
form that was on the side.
This is a very
important formula.
Incidentally, the
two that appears here
is only because when we write
this in a different notation,
this term will occur
twice, once as dx times dy,
and once as dy times dx.
And the two times it occurs
are equal to each other,
so here they're just collected
together with a factor of two
in front.
Yes.
STUDENT: Just to make sure,
those three different functions
you wrote, those
subscripts aren't
supposed to mean partial
derivatives, right?
PROFESSOR: No, that's right.
The subscripts and
this expression
only mean that this
multiplies dx squared,
so it has subscripts xx.
And this multiplies dx times
dy, so it has subscripts xy.
That's what the subscripts
mean and nothing more.
So the subscripts
only mean that they're
the things that appear
in that equation.
Yes.
STUDENT: It seems like
the metric is giving us
distance in terms of an
infintesimal displacement,
but then a locally Euclidean
space is already tangent
infintesimally, so how are
we relating the local metric
with the global metric?
PROFESSOR: OK, the
question is how
do we relate the local
metric which I say
is Euclidean to
the global metric?
And the answer I
think for now I will
stick to just giving kind
of a pictorial answer based
on the picture here.
That is once you know the
distances between any two
points in a tiny
little patch here,
it's then always possible
to construct coordinates,
here called x prime
and y prime, such
that the distance between
any two points as calculated
from the original metric,
which is the one here,
is exactly the same
as the distance you
get using this metric.
And the claim is
that you can always
define coordinates x prime and
y prime which make that true.
That claim is not
absolutely obvious.
But it's something you can
probably visualize if you just
imagine that every little tiny
piece of this curved surface
looks like it was just
a flat surface and then
a flat surface you know
that you can write down
a Cartesian coordinate system,
which will have the Euclidean
metric.
But it's only an
intuitive statement,
proving it is actually harder.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
bottom formula [INAUDIBLE]
with positive curvature if we
analogize to second derivative.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
say that again.
STUDENT: If we
analogize gxx, gyy,
in the bottom formula there,
[INAUDIBLE] positive curvature
[INAUDIBLE] second derivative--
PROFESSOR: Yeah OK.
So you're asking does
this mean that we
have two states of
positive curvature?
STUDENT: Bottom right.
PROFESSOR: Bottom
right, oh this.
These are Mustafa's slides.
I forgot to say that.
You can tell from the style,
these are not my slides,
these are Mustafa's slides.
And I don't know what
he meant by this.
You're right, this
does-- well you
do want the metric
to be positive
definite, which is not the
same as saying the curvature
is positive.
And I think this might
just be the condition
that the metric is
positive definite,
that this expression
will always be positive.
Yeah.
I'll bet that's what it
is, I don't know for sure.
I'll bet that's what
that condition is about.
And you do want that,
the metric had better
be positive definite
for spatial geometries.
In fact, in general relativity,
where it's a space time metric,
it will not be
positive definite.
For reasons that we'll
talk about later.
But for geometry, the metric
should be positive definite.
All distances
should be positive.
OK.
So that ends my slides.
So now I'll continue
on the blackboard.
OK next I wanted to say
a few general comments
about general relativity.
General relativity was of
course invented by the Einstein
in 1916.
It's a theory that he was
working on for about 10 years
after he invented the theory
of special relativity.
To understand what's
going on there,
you want to recognize
that special relativity is
a theory of mechanics
and electrodynamics
which was designed to be
consistent with the principle
that the speed of
light is always
the same speed of light
independent of the speed
of the source of light or
the speed of the observer
of the light.
And it's of course
not easy to do that,
because you think that if you
move relative to something
else that's moving, that you
would see its velocity change.
So in order to make a theory
that where the speed of light
was an absolute
invariant, Einstein
had introduced a
number of things.
And we talked about
those at the beginning
of the course, the three
primary effects built
in to special relativity.
Time dilation,
length contraction,
and new rules
about simultaneity,
and how things that look
simultaneous to one observer
will not look simultaneous
to other observers in a very
definite, well defined way.
So by inventing
these rules, Einstein
was able to devise
a system which
was consistent with the
idea that the speed of light
always looked the
same to all observers.
And at similar times, the
Michelson Morley experiment
seemed to show that that
was in fact the case
and ultimately there's a
tremendous amount of evidence
verifying that what the
hypothesis that Einstein was
pursuing is the right one
for the way nature behaves.
The speed of light is invariant.
But what was lacking in
Einstein's formulation
of special relativity
was any version
of a consistent
theory of gravity.
Gravity had a well defined
description known since Newton.
But Newton's description
was a description
of a force at a distance.
And that is intrinsically
inconsistent with a theory
like special relativity,
which holds that simultaneity
is itself relative.
In Newtonian physics,
the force of gravity
is equal to Newton's
constant times
the product of the
two masses that
are interacting with
each other divided
by the square of the distance
and then times some union
vector pointing along the line
that joins the two particles.
But for that formula to
make any sense at all,
you have to know where
the two particles are
at the same instant of time.
And this r is the distance
between the locations
of the two particles at
some instant of time.
And this r hat is
a unit vector that
points along the line joining
those two particles where
you've pinned down where
those particles are
at one instant of time.
But we know from
the very beginning
that in special relativity the
notion of two things happening
at distant points at one
instant of time is ambiguous.
Different observers will
see different notions
of what it means for
two events to happen
at the same time
across this distance.
And that means there's
no way to make sense out
of Newton's Law of
gravity in the context
of special relativity.
You can't modify
it by just changing
the way the force
depends on distance.
You really have to
change the variables
that it depends on
from the beginning.
Yes.
STUDENT: Is that equivalent to
saying the other particle can't
know how much mass
of one is [INAUDIBLE]
limit of the information
of the speed of light?
PROFESSOR: Is that equivalent to
saying that one particle can't
know what the mass
of the other particle
is because of limitation.
Yeah it's the distance,
it's not the mass.
Because the mass is
preserved in time.
So one particle
could've measured
the mass of the other
particle at an earlier time
and it would be
reasonable to infer,
given the laws of
physics, that we
know that would stay the same.
But one particle
has no way of where
the other particle
is at the same time.
And not only does the particle
not have any way of knowing,
but even an external
observer can't know.
Because different
external observers
will have different
definitions of what
it means to be at the same time.
So there really is no
way that this could work.
Now I should mention
that it is still
possible to have action
at a distance theories
which are consistent
with special relativity.
And in fact, Maxwell's equations
can be reformulated that way.
The easiest way to
make things consistent
with special relativity is
to describe interactions
in terms of fields.
And that is really what
Einstein did originally
in special relativity.
He was thinking
about light, he was
thinking about
Maxwell's equations
and he was thinking very
explicitly about Maxwell's
equations.
And in the Maxwell description
of electromagnetism,
particles at a
distance don't directly
interact with each other.
But rather, each
particle interacts
with the fields around it and
that is a local interaction.
A particle interacts
directly only
with the fields
at the same point.
But then those fields
obey wave equations
that can propagate information.
And the fact that
you have an electron
here can create a
field which then
exerts a force on
an electron there.
And the force on
the electron here
depends only on the
electric fields here
or the magnetic fields as well.
The particle is moving, but
everything is completely local
and the description
of electromagnetism as
given in the form of
Maxwell's equations.
And Maxwell's equations are
completely relativistically
invariant.
And that was part of
Einstein's-- it was really
the key part of Einstein's
motivation in constructing
the theory of special relativity
in the first place to make
Maxwell's equations invariant.
That they held in every frame.
It is still possible
though and worth
recognizing that it's possible
to reformulate electromagnetism
as an action at a
distance theory.
And it is in fact
described that way
in volume one of
the Feynman lectures
for those of you who've looked
at the Feynman lectures.
In order to make
that work, you have
to complicate things in
a pretty significant way.
So I'm going to draw here
just a space time diagram.
X and CT, CT going up that
way, x going that way.
So in this diagram
the speed of light
would be a 45 degree line.
And let's suppose we have
two particles traveling
in this space.
A particle that I will
call a and a particle
that I will call b.
Being very original
with these names.
If we wanted to know
the force on particle a
at a certain time t indicated
by this dotted line,
I guess I'll label t to make
it as clear as possible.
Feynman gives us a formula
where we can determine it
solely in terms of the
motion of particle B
without talking
about fields at all.
But the formula does not depend
on where b is at the same time.
And it could not
if this is going
to be a relativistic
description.
But instead, the way this action
and the distance formulation
works is when imagine drawing
a 45 degree line backwards,
meaning a line that
light could travel on,
and one sees where
that intersects
the trajectory of particle
B. And that time is t prime.
And the word that's used for
that symbol is retarded time.
It's an earlier time.
It's exactly that time which has
the property that if particle
b emitted a light
beam at that time,
it would be arriving at
particle a at just the time
t that we're interested
in the time when we're
trying to calculate the
force on particle a.
And what Feynman gives you in
volume one if you look at it
is a very complicated
formula that
determines the
force on particle a
in terms of not only the
position of this particle
at time t prime but also
its velocity and even
its acceleration.
But if you do know the
position, the velocity,
and the acceleration
of this particle,
and of course the
velocity of particle a,
you can determine
the force on a.
Not obvious, but it's true.
But that's certainly
not the easiest way
to formulate electromagnetism.
And that's not the way
most of us have learned,
unless you've
learned by starting
by reading volume
one of Feynman.
But most of us learn
Maxwell's equations
as differential equations.
Where information is propagated
by the field from one
point to another.
In the case of
general relativity,
one has the same problem.
How can you describe
something which--
and the only approximate
you initially
know is an action
and the distance,
how can you describe
it in a way that's
consistent with relativity?
And the idea that simultaneity
is not a well defined concept.
So that was the
problem was Einstein
was wrestling with
for 10 years, how
to build a theory
of gravity that
would be consistent with
the basic principles
of special relativity.
And the result of those
10 years of cogitating
is the theory that we
call general relativity.
And it's essentially
a theory which
describes gravity
as a field theory
similar to Maxwell's
field theory
where all interactions
are local.
Nothing interacts at a
distance, but particles interact
with fields at the
same point, the fields
can propagate information
by obeying wave equations,
and the fields then
at a distant point
can exert forces
on other particles.
But in the case of general
relativity, what Einstein
concluded was that the
fields that were relevant,
the fields that
described gravity,
were in fact the metric
of space and time.
So general relativity
is the field theory
of the metric of space and time.
And gravity is described
solely as a distortion
of space and time.
And that's what general
relativity is about
and that's what we will
be learning more about.
Now as I said earlier, now
I can say it perhaps more
explicitly, what we
will be learning about
is how to describe the
curvature of space time
as general relativity
describes it.
We will learn how that
curvature affects things
like the motions of particles.
But we will not in
this course learn
how the presence of
particles and masses
affects the curvature
of space time.
That you'll have to take it in
a relativity course to learn.
OK, I think that's where
we'll be stopping today.
Just doesn't pay to start a new
topic with a minute and a half
left.
But let me just ask if
there are any questions.
OK, well class
over, I will see you
folks in a week, because
there's no class next Tuesday.